- Le prix des maisons a-t-il
réellement grimpé de 300 000 $
en cinq ans au Canada?
Oui, c'est vrai. Le prix moyen
d'une propriété, tout type
confondu, est passé de
434 000 $ en novembre 2015
à 736 000 $ en juillet dernier,
selon l'indice des prix MLS.
La hausse dépasse donc un peu
les  300 000 $.
On a reculé jusqu'en 2006,
quand les conservateurs
de Stephen Harper ont formé
le gouvernement, pour voir
comment les prix ont évolué.
On le voit sur le graphique,
il y a eu une accélération
importante à compter de 2016
et il y en a eu une autre avec
la pandémie.
Les prix sont encore plus élevés
à Vancouver et à Toronto,
alors que Montréal arrive
sous la moyenne canadienne.
Pourquoi les prix ont grimpé
aussi rapidement? Parce que
le déséquilibre entre l'offre
et la demande s'est accentué.
Selon un rapport de la Banque
Scotia, la croissance de la
population a été plus importante
dans les cinq dernières années,
notamment en raison de
l'immigration.
Au Canada, il y a 424 unités de
logement pour chaque millier de
personnes. C'est plus faible que
dans tous les autres pays du G7,
qui en comptent en moyenne 471.
Pour en arriver là, il faudrait
construire 1,8 million de
maisons. Selon l'OCDE, de tous
les pays du G7, c'est au Canada
que le prix des maisons a grimpé
le plus rapidement depuis